-Our first guests tonight ar
two very funny comedians
and writers you know
from their work
on "Saturday Night Live"
and "30 Rock."
You also know Paula as one
of the stars of "A.P. Bio,
which returns on Peacock
this September.
Their new show,
"Mapleworth Murders,"
is currently streaming on Quib
with new episodes
released every Monday.
Let's take a look.
-Chief of police
coming through.
Look at this goddamn
fruit roll-up.
Mapleworth, everywhere you go,
someone gets killed.
I'd never invite you to a party,
especially a surprise party.
-I would.
Having one of my guests ge
murdered is worth having
Mrs. Mapleworth grace me
with her dancing charismas
-Pewntz, come on, man!
You're getting all worked up
for nothing!
I need you to go to my car
and get my crown seam gloves
Not my fishing gloves,
not my miming gloves,
not my falcon gloves.
They only sell those one
at a time anyways. It's not two.
You've never seen a person wit
two falcon gloves, have you?
-Yeah, I --
-You've seen somebody standing
around in the park
with two hands up like this?
-Yeah, maybe I misremembered
-Here's my conversation
with our good friends
Paula Pell
and our very own John Lutz
John and Paula,
how are you guys?
-Hi.
-Hello.
-It's so nice to see you both.
The three of us used to
all work together
at "Saturday Night Live"
as writers.
And now, Paula, I'm lucky enough
to work with you on "A.P. Bio.
And, John, you're still a writer
on "Late Night."
And yet this is your first tim
as a guest
on this show via Zoom.
-Yes, via Zoom.
The way I wanted to do it.
[ Laughter ]
-This will not impress
any of your colleagues
on the writing staff.
-No, not at all.
-Basically the last thing
you did in the studio
was a very popular sketch
of yours.
-Yes.
There's a thing called
where you -- you're supposed t
look on your phone and look at
the last normal photo
that happened before quarantine.
And my last photo is from
something I did on the show,
and it is this.
It's Squattle.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, there you go.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-It should be noted that
your last normal photo
was already fairly abnormal.
-[ Laughs ]
Yes, definitely.
-That is also
my vaginal sonogram.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, Paula, you know,
a lot of people have had sort of
shipping mishaps,
mostly because, you know,
there's so many more package
being sent during quarantine
And then also the mail
is slowing down.
But before this started, you had
a shipping mishap with Amazon.
-Yeah. We've been ordering
everything on Amazon obviously
And -- That was not sponsored.
But we've been ordering
constantly, and I'm a little -
I'm always a little nervou
because last --
right after we finished
"Mapleworth,"
we finished shooting, and I wa
just thinking, you know,
I was going to buy myself
a gift for Christmas.
And I realized that all my
vibrators had kind of turned
They sort of went bad,
and they just turned.
They had deteriorated
from lack of use.
So I ordered one on Amazon
And I never got it.
And then I went home
for Christmas,
and then I had
a great Christmas,
and I came back
from Florida to L.A.,
and I was sitting one day,
and it said -- it didn't say
"your vibrator has arrived,"
but it said
"your package has arrived.
And I looked,
and it had arrived,
but it wasn't on my front stoop,
and I couldn't figure it out
for like a whole day.
I was like, "Oh, I got to call
them. They're wrong," you know
And then I looked on my e-mail
and Amazon had sent me a photo
of the box, which was on m
mother's front stoop in Florida.
-[ Laughs ]
-I had sent it
to the wrong address
with a lot of poinsettias
and, like, a little beagle
that says "welcome," you know.
And it's my artificial
schlong in a box.
[ Laughter ]
-So what did you do?
-So I called my parents,
and I was just, you know,
like 10 years old, like gettin
caught doing something bad
And like, "Hey, just by the way,
there was some stupid mishap
There's something I ordered.
It's just a stupid thing.
Just, you know, don't open it.
Just put it in another box
or put another label on it
and just send it."
So about a week later, I got it,
and it was in a completely
different box
and wrapped in Orlando Sentine
newspaper.
So clearly they had opened
the whole thing up
and then lovingly wrapped it
And my mom said
something about a shaver.
I think she thought it was lik
a little -- a little --
-Oh, I see. Gotcha.
-But she's gonna know now!
-[ Laughs ]
This is also, I will say,
the gift you rewarded yourself
with post-"Mapleworth"
was thematic.
There are some vibrator-adjacent
jokes in the show.
-Yes.
Abigail, my character,
Abigail Mapleworth,
has a drawer full of
"neck massagers."
-Right.
-And she really sticks to
that theory that
they are neck massagers
for mature women and all matur
women have neck massagers
when they're stressed out.
-[ Laughs ]
Now, John, this is an idea
you came up with,
and the minute I heard it --
-Not the vibrators.
Not the vibrators.
-Not the vibrators part.
Paula was very kind to add her
personal experience to the show.
-That's in my rider. That'
on my rider of my contract
[ Laughter ]
-How did you -- How did
this idea occur to you, John
-Well, I was trying to write
something for me,
and I just had a bunch of
writer's block.
And so my wife Sue,
Sue Galloway, who you know
said, "Why don't you just -- You
should write something for Paula
because she's the funniest
person we know."
And then I went off for like
five minutes and came back
immediately with this idea
because I thought of her,
just picturing Paula
as like a Miss Marple
or a Jessica Fletcher characte
just fit perfectly,
and then pitched it to Paula
and it just all fell into place.
-It was one of those calls
because sometimes you get a call
of like, "Hey, I was thinkin
what if this."
And you're like, "I'm gonn
think about that."
And he called me with that
and I was like,
"When can we immediately
do this?
Oh, my God."
And then we found
a home at Quibi.
-And you did find a home
at Quibi, and one of the thing
you also found yourself
doing was watching
old "Murder, She Wrotes."
And while they are not --
I mean, it's light drama.
Like, the show was never
too scary or too dark,
but it's also very funny
to go back
and watch those old episodes
-Yeah. I love -- I love how --
one that John and I watched,
we got hysterically laughing
was, you know,
everything at "SNL" is lik
boom, boom, boom,
and everything in television
and everything has got to be
you know, under time.
And we started watching
this episode,
and she was in a nightclub
with her niece
because she has 8,000 nieces
in every town.
And she's ordering wine,
and it was just this kind of
little bit of curious music,
and she was looking at the men
like, "Hmm, I think
I'll have a white wine."
And then you're just like,
"What is the clue?"
Like, what is this
gonna connect to?
No connection whatsoever.
They were like, "Fill
the front half of the show
A couple special guests
fell through.
We can't shoot at the Taj Maha
now, so we can't do the remote
So just -- just fill it up."